hello guys welcome back to a new video
on matrix math / linear algebra today
we're going to be starting on
simultaneous linear equations and these
are pretty cool and end up actually
being rather important because they are
in a lot of ways how you end up doing
computations but today we're just gonna
kind of introduce linear systems and
what simultaneous linear equations are
so let me go ahead and get into it here
so what a linear equation is is
basically some matrices that can line up
to be an equation it looks like my
computer wants me to do something
alright so trying to think how to
explain this without overcomplicating it
let's say we have let's just start with
a few examples so I'm gonna use my draw
tool here oh that's a huge circle we
don't need a circle that big hold it
about this size okay so say we have a
matrix a and it is a four by four I
don't know we'll just put some random
stuff in it for now zero 1 2 3 - 7 6 4
more ones down here that's an ugly
matrix make sure so we don't worry about
it it's just a 4 by 4 matrix hold on I'm
explaining this all wrong is thank you
no we're good
this is right so you have a matrix with
a bunch of variables in it and then you
have another one that is just a vector
let's call it X in this case and this is
what your unknowns are and this is
typically a column vector that will look
like something like this X Y Z and then
W
and then you have a result vector that
looks something like this it's just
usually called B and we just have the
results we'll have B 1 B 2 B 3 before
now as you might have noticed with most
math stuff it doesn't really matter what
you name it as long as you understand
what your names mean so go with what you
will hear
but basically what ends up happening is
you take each row of this matrix and you
put the X plus the y plus 2z plus the W
and it has to add up like that so it's
like X plus while 0 it's gonna be no
wise so end up being plus Z and then
this 2 will be the W plus 2w so this
this row here this top row would turn
into the linear system looking our
linear equation looking like this X plus
y plus 2w and I hope you understand that
but just to be super clear this one goes
with this X the 0 goes with this y
that's why there is no oh this should be
a Z little error there on my part you
won't see the Y since the and the Y slot
it's a 0 so there's just nothing there
but if you want to line up sometimes
you'll have to leave a spot there where
it is and I did it again
i put a y there again all right it's a Z
so ok so one goes the X zero goes to the
Y and this one goes to the Z and then
this 2 over here goes to the W and then
what we get here is it equals whatever
is over here so a little equal well be 1
and y you can't solve this on your own
you could do some substitution which we
will talk about in the next video as we
learn how to solve these but right now
we're just kind of figuring out how to
organize them so if you wanted to do
this next row we got a 4 I want a 3 a 2
2 it would look like
for x+ let's see 1y which is just Y
because it's implied that there's a 1 in
front of it plus 3z plus 2w and that
will equal B 2 and so on you could do
that with this next row in this next row
this one's all 1 so the very last row is
just all 1 so it'd be X plus y plus Z
plus W equals before and this one before
it would be 7 X 6 plus 6 y plus Z plus W
equals p3 so yeah that's that's kind of
how you set them up let me just read a
few things here let's see this the
solution the solution over here is a set
of scalars so these want to you want
these to be actual results and a scalar
is usually just a single number so you
don't want this these be ones to end up
being another big equation at the end
you want to actually solve them it's the
point but as we will find out you can't
always fully solve them so sometimes you
just have to get as far as you can get
and call it what it is all right let's
make a new layer here apparently I was
drawing on this background layer some so
I'm going to just make a little
correction here and we'll delete those
layers okay and we'll delete this layer
too okay so let's move on here we got it
just a few more things to show you but
that's really the gist of it is just
understanding how to set them up so
let's do a little example some of these
are really easy to solve and you can
kind of figure them out so other ones
are a little more difficult so we're
going to do example one here that's a
new one let's say we have
this system and they want to want us to
convert it to matrix form we have X plus
let's say 2 y will do a minus here minus
Z plus W and we'll say equals 4 and then
the other equation we have is X plus 3y
plus 2z M plus 4 W equals 9 that's a 4
that's a 9
ok hopefully those are readable on the
screen so if you want to turn this into
a matrix we basically do the reverse of
what we did before
we'll call the matrix just these numbers
in front of the letters so it's going to
be a let's see a 2x4 two rows four
columns so it looks like we got a 1 2 a
negative 1 and a 1 so a 1 2 a negative 1
and a 1 and then on this next row we
have a 1 a 3 a 2 a 4 1 3 2 4 and it
looks like the XYZ is pretty standard so
we will call this I'll put a comma here
we'll call just the X what it is X Y C W
X Y Z W and then we have the solution
which we're going to call B and it is
going to be these numbers 4 & 9 for 9
and there we go we have successfully
turned that to this linear system right
here of equations into matrix form here
and that would be the answer if you were
just asked to convert it to matrix form
so these can get more complicated there
could be more rows if any of these are
missing like if there's just no
see here it's assumed that there was a
zero in front of the Z so it would be a
zero
so just so that's clear and now what
you'll find as you try to solve these is
sometimes there will be no solutions
sometimes there will be just one
solution and sometimes there will be
multiple solutions so there's some
different different things here if there
are no canned no solutions the system is
called inconsistent so I'll make a new
layer for that and we'll just do some
typing here so no solutions equals and
consistent and we want to say if there
are solutions that means one or more
I'll put one plus there then it is
consistent so we have some different
systems there and now there's a one more
thing about the answer that be let's see
here this here this this B alright now
what we want to say about that is
basically let's go back to this tool
let's see if B so V B is a vector if B
ends up equal equaling zero which means
everything in it is zero then we get a
let's see we get a homogeneous function
then it is call it a modulus I hope I'm
saying that right
gorian spelling it right there we go so
right yeah that's right if B is not
equal to zero I don't have it not equal
so I'm gonna use the C++ syntax of the
apostrophe there so if B is not zero
that means there's something in that
vector that is not zero in it can be
anything
then this
system is called non-homogeneous okay so
that's the very first intro to these
linear systems equations the next couple
videos will be going over how to solve
them and we'll also be going over the
best way for computers to solve them in
case you're programming these sorts of
things all right thank you for watching
hope you all have a great day take care
of yourselves and stay warm I don't know
about you guys but where I'm at it's
really cold so peace out